[Music]
e
you might ask why I would be concerned
with bringing the history of the Bible
to a more popular
audience we inevitably and must see the
world through the lens of a
story a story is a description of the
implicit structure through which we view
the world and prioritize our perceptions
and determine how to act now because you
can act in a very large variety of ways
that plethora of possibility has to be
limited and focused it has to come to a
point it has to have a destination it
has to have a moral it has to have an
ethic and what a story is is a
description of an ethic of attentional
and action
prioritization peace is dependent upon
us being brought together under the
rubric of a single centralizing
narrative much of which is reflected in
The Meta narrative that the biblical
Library
constitutes so I hope you enjoy this
tour through the history of the world's
most significant
book all right internet I have returned
I'm still Dave Ruben this still is the
Reuben report it's November 3rd 2023
where has this year gone we are live
streaming on the rumble on the YouTube
on the locals if you want to join us for
a post game show today after the show uh
Ruben report. locals.com and by the way
we are doing our first ever test show we
are launching a new show at 100 p.m
Eastern Monday through Thursday next
week a call-in show so you guys can get
involved in what we're doing here it is
one of the pieces that I have wanted to
integrate into everything else we're
doing uh for a couple years now we
finally figured out a way we can make it
work we're going to be launching that
next week it's going to be Monday
through Thursdays 1: p.m. Eastern we're
doing our first test show with our
locals Community a just to make sure we
got the tech right and everything else
so I've posted about that in Lo locals
if you want to check it out the cold
open today uh obviously was Jordan
Peterson talking about the importance of
stories in that case biblical stories
specifically and the reason that I
wanted to use that as the cold open uh
is because I am just back from 5 days in
London at Jordan Peterson's Arc
conference the alliance for responsible
citizenship and you know in light of the
last three and a half weeks worth of
news or almost a month now now worth of
news uh we have needed some some
positive stories to be told we have
needed some Resurgence of the good ideas
to put away the bad ideas and we we are
seeing bad ideas just burst forth and
proliferate everywhere some of us have
been warning about it and even those who
have been warning about it I think are
somewhat surprised that the level of uh
depravity uh not just in the barbaric
acts themselves but the response on so
many college campuses and from from so
many of our political leaders and people
in the west and all of that stuff but
the ark conference Arc which stands for
the alliance for responsible citizenship
was so absolutely wonderful I just want
to run through a couple pictures here uh
that was me and Ben Shapiro he was the
surprise guest at Jordan's last uh show
there was a huge show about 20,000
people at the O2 it was just Jordan at
his absolute best there's Jordan at the
O2 you can see and and Jordan and his
wife Tammy and there's there's a rare
picture of my producer Phoenix go back
to that one there you go there's Phoenix
and you can see me in the background uh
and we did we shot about 20 interviews
uh you'll recognize a whole bunch of
those people from Eric Weinstein and uh
former speaker Kevin McCarthy although
as he calls himself once and always
speaker Kevin McCarthy Brett Weinstein
Andy no uh and many more so we're going
to be releasing a lot of those
throughout the week oh there's one more
so that's from The Arc conference itself
I just really like that cool shot that's
Jordan on stage with Ian hery Ali former
former deputy Prime Minister of
Australia John Anderson and some other
folks uh and it was just absolutely
inspiring you know the last couple weeks
have definitely I think they've taken a
toll on everybody and we're all kind of
looking to that shining City like where
is it which way are we supposed to be
going what is the the vision for the
future that will be positive and it was
just so great to be around so many
people it was an invite only event for
the three days and then the the O2 event
was public but to be around you know
about 1500 people that we had all sorts
of political differences there were
people really much more on the right
there were PE some people it was harder
to find you know sort of people really
on the left but like everybody from all
these different countries I think they
said there were 73 countries represented
there uh and it was really just
wonderful and inspiring and just one
other thing before we get to the show
today which is sort of framed around
that idea how do we have a vision for
the future and perhaps it's by looking
back into our past maybe we did do some
good stuff maybe our ancestors weren't
all backwards racist bigoted homophobes
uh but one other comment real quick I
seriously missed you guys uh you know I
was in LA for a couple days before we
went to London we did that show with uh
with RFK that live event there so I
really haven't been in show in studio
for about a week and a half and you know
the show has grown in such a way over
the last couple weeks especially and I
know you guys are looking you know every
every weekday at that 11:00 Eastern to
to get a little bit of insight or
whatever it is that I offer here uh and
I missed you and I thought about you
every day and we tried couple times we
were trying to figure out if there was a
way we could live stream from there but
there were just so many things going on
anyway for the rest of the year I'm
basically is it fair to say that I'm
basically here I'm basically in Miami
and uh yeah we will not be taking any
days off and as I said we're add in the
second show also later in this week is
the next Republican debate from Miami so
I think we'll have a couple surprises
around that and there we go so the theme
a vision for the future by looking back
into our past and I thought we could uh
we could lay it out with a couple bullet
points who who is the enemy right now
right we seem very confused about that
uh what is the action of the enemy what
are they doing right now that seems to
be unfurling so many things uh what is
the consequence of those actions in
America and the West what are our
solutions to what they are doing and
finally I think that there is a solution
and it's that bottomup approach that
Jordan Peterson often talks about so I
thought a nice way to start this would
be a clip that maybe some of you have
seen because it was a couple days ago
while I was gone uh but Elon Musk was on
Joe Rogan's show and they were talking
about George Soros and George Soros as
you guys know he is the the globalist
billionaire who has funded so many of
the politicians and the Das uh who have
ruined so many of our cities and Elon uh
well Joe asked Elon what he thought
about George Soros uh and I thought this
was quite
interesting you one often hears of the
sort of George sorus Boogeyman but I
mean sorus
actually you know he he is I believe the
top contributor to the Democratic party
um the second one was uh Sam back
freed so and sorus I don't know I mean
he had a very difficult
upbringing um and uh I in my opinion he
fundamentally hates Humanity but that's
my opinion really yeah I mean well he's
doing things that erode the fabric of
civilization you know uh getting da is
elected who refuse to prosecute crime
that's part of the problem in San
Francisco and la and bu of other cities
so why would you do
that was it Humanity or is it just the
United States as a whole I mean other
countries too same thing yeah I should
note that that was from the Halloween
episode of The Joe Rogan show Joe is not
going trans unless I missed something I
haven't been on Twitter much the last
couple I guess anything's possible
anything for clicks right um anyway this
idea that George Soros that the things
that he puts money towards these Das all
over the place right and we know where
they are right they're in San Francisco
they're in Los Angeles as a matter of
fact when I went up to San Francisco to
meet with Elon Musk a couple months ago
we stood in his office which is a corner
office in Twitter and he was just
pointing around oh that's where they get
the the drugs that's where they do the
drugs the police are standing right
there they don't do anything so he has
seen the way it has systemically you can
say the word systemically in this case
it's an overused word destroyed San
Francisco you know about Los Angeles we
did have a a Soros back da here in
Florida Ronda santis got rid of him uh
but here's an interesting moment so you
can agree or disagree with with musk's
notion that Soros hates Humanity uh but
he then lays out what he is actually
doing what Soros actually figured out
it's not that you have to break laws to
destroy a society you just have to not
enforce laws and that's an important
distinction take a look George at this
point is pretty old I mean he's
not uh you know he's basically a butenol
at this point but I mean he he and he's
he's he's very smart um and he's very
good at Arbitrage you know famously he
uh shed the British pound that's sort of
how
I think he made his first money was
shorting the pound um so he's good at
spotting uh basically Arbitrage like
spotting value for money that other
people don't see so uh one of the things
he noticed was that
in that that the value for money in
local races is much higher than it is in
National races so the lowest value for
money is a presidential race then next
lowest value for money is a senate race
then a Congress and but once you get to
sort of city and state district
attorneys um the value for money is
extremely good and Soros realized that
you don't actually need to change the
laws you just need to change how they're
enforced if nobody chooses to enforce
the law or the laws are differentially
enforced it's like changing the
laws that's what he that's what he
figured out this is a really really
important point and I think you'll see
how I'm connecting it to everything else
going on in the world right now it's
complex from an American perspective to
change laws whether it's a city law or a
state law or a federal law you have to
go through the either the state senate
or the the Senate nationally Congress
Etc or you can push people into office
you can back people who will simply not
do their job and the system doesn't know
how to really react to those people so
that for example might be a district
attorney say George gascan who is now
the da of Los Angeles who does not
enforce laws he doesn't enforce trespass
passing laws you can do drugs on the
street you can get away with petty theft
you're literally allowed to steal under
I think it's
$899 worth of stuff so you can walk into
a Best Buy take a PlayStation 5 how much
is that running these days PS5 about 400
you could take about what you could get
about four games another like 50 bucks a
game or they're usually about 70 bucks a
game now right so you get maybe three
games but if you go over that 899 then
maybe they'll arrest you but we know
they're not going to do that you've all
seen the videos of CBS and Dwayne Reed
all these uh depart drug stores and
department stores that are just Barren
because they have to put stuff you know
either the shelves are completely Barren
or they have to put stuff behind glass
so you can't get like a Gillette razor
unless you actually ask someone like
you've all seen all of this but it's an
important distinction what what he's
saying Soros decided oh we don't have to
do the work the work would be getting
people elected who will change the laws
we can actually just get a bunch of
people who will not enforce them right
this is a fundamental difference and
it's a easier way to destroy Society by
the way that was one of the reasons
there were many reasons mostly related
to co but it was one of the reasons that
I left Los Angeles I felt that if
something uh if someone had shown up to
the door of my house and we had our mail
broke into and a bunch more but if
someone had hopped the fence for example
you were allowed to trespass if someone
had you know tried to barge into my
house that simply they would not have
done anything if I had taken action to
protect myself and my property and my
family I would be the enemy so this is
what Soros has basically seeded Across
the Nation right and then what he does
is also his his uh Das they bounce
around so George gasan Who as I said is
now the da of Los Angeles he is the
former da of San Francisco so he he
actually destroyed San Francisco and
then they move him right and that's
Democrat privilege you never pay the
price for what you do you just get moved
elsewhere so now I want to connect this
to something else because it's not just
the Das right you could also get people
in charge of say I don't know the
Department of Homeland Security who
simply will not do their job you could
get people at the federal level who are
supposed to protect our borders and they
simply will not do that uh check this
out this video is going viral uh over
the last couple days uh this is our
Southern border and you tell me are the
people in charge of the Border doing
their job or
[Music]
not
I think you know the answer to the
question that I posed but isn't that
interesting these people who are
seemingly all young right they're all
young it's largely male it seems about
80% male but all young they all look
like they're in their 20s 30s maybe 40s
right uh this is very different than say
I don't know 1920s 30s America when we
had a great boom of immigration largely
from Eastern Europe and you would see
the poor and the tired and the Huddle
masses and old women with one jacket and
people coming across with nothing these
people are wearing pretty decent clothes
they don't seem like they're really
fleeing much of anything but that's a
sidebar to the larger issue the larger
issue is we have not gotten rid of any
of our laws we as a society have decided
to stop enforcing them and unfortunately
I have to say we because even you
watching this if you did not vote for
any of these people uh it is the society
that we're part of and we have to fix
that thing uh because what's happening
now is that then often these people come
here and they create all sorts of crime
all sorts of stress on our system and if
you say anything about it you are then
called a yes A Nazi even though it's the
people that are defending Hamas and the
rest of it that are acting like the real
Nazis but then what happens also is that
the media starts getting everything
backwards right and they start defending
the bad guys and the criminals and the
illegals and taking out the good people
so here's a here's a story this is from
uh Texas over the last couple days uh
and there is a young teenage kid I will
make no note of his race you can decide
if you think there's a racial element to
to this yourself uh who went up to a
complete stranger at a park and slugged
him you're going to see the video this
is from Cypress Texas and watch how the
media frames the story this kid who
attacked this man for no particular
reason watch the the suck job that the
media did 19-year-old Alfred Lewis spoke
with me about how he feels about it now
you know I just made a mistake and
everybody makes mistakes this is the
video in question first shared with kou1
via the next door app in it you can
clearly see Lewis striking a man in the
head from behind before he turns around
in shock I know like from the video all
you see is like the bad part about it
but um what people didn't see was that I
shook his hand after and I had gave the
man a hug that is something we cannot
verify nor can we confirm that another
man seen in the video getting punched
and grabbed later left on good terms
according to Lewis I really didn't
expect for it to just go so left you
know I have a lot of questions about
that um so he beats the crap basically
could have killed that guy like a slug
like that from the back of your head
when you're not expecting it absolutely
could kill you absolutely could put you
in a coma right uh but now the media
does this job on him well what did he
think about he didn't realize it was
going to go so crazy that the video is
only showing you a portion he hugged the
guy so he claims there's no video
evidence of the of the uh of the hug but
the reason I'm showing you this that is
a micro version of something that has
burst forth throughout Society if you
had the race situation backwards on that
right so let's just say I don't know
that kid looked like he was what 15 16
years old 15 16y old white kid ran up
behind a random black dude and slugged
him like that we would have riots in the
street Barack Obama would be saying that
guy looked like my son or my cousin but
when it doesn't fit the narrative we
suddenly humanize the people and we we
neutralize the vice and crime that they
are causing all over our city
and towns so now I want to show you one
other thing I unfortunately missed
Halloween here the boys did dress up we
got a lion and a tiger here uh but I
unfortunately missed Halloween but I
want to show you this this video that
was also going viral over the last
couple days this is what appears it's a
little unclear if these are illegal
immigrants or not so I'm going to put
that aside for a moment but this is a
video from Halloween that was going
viral uh well take a look at the video
and again this is somewhat irrelevant
whether they are illegal or not I want
to talk about Behavior specifically and
how we reward all of the wrong things
that Society starts collapsing so take a
[Music]
look
okay so it's unclear to the internet
whether those people are illegal or not
they obviously weren't speaking English
it's actually a a moot well it's not
completely moot point whether they were
illegal or not but I'm talking now more
about Behavior right because that video
was going viral and it's like what are
those people teaching those children
like and and I think you can see how it
starts with that right if you have
parents who tell your kids go ahead and
steal take everyone else El's candy not
only take everyone else's candy we'll do
it with you by the way you shouldn't be
eating all that candy that's I guess a
sidebar to all this but if you start
with that sort of thing you can see how
those kids might grow up and then walk
into a Best Buy and say I'd like Call of
Duty I don't have any cash I'm going to
take it and I'm going to punch this
security guard on the way out so these
things actually are deeply connected and
then what happens is mainstream media
punishes all the wrong people they
constantly go after all of the wrong
people so now I want to show you a video
I believe this is from yesterday of
quote unquote of late night quote
unquote comedian Steph colar and think
of all of the things that are happening
in the world right now all of the bad
people who should be exposed right now
all of the wrongs that this guy could
hit if he was an actual comedian
speaking truth to power but no no no
he's going after the orange
man wow then Trump waiting on the
attorneys that flipped on him down in
the Georgia election fraud case if you
want to challenge the result of an
election they Hound you look what
happened this weekend with two good
people they hound them and they scare
them and they but we don't get scared we
don't get scared I'll tell you what I
don't mind being Nelson
Mandela no no no no no no no no I also
don't mind him being Nelson Mandela spe
specifically the part where he goes to
jail for 27
years wow oh haha the Applause sign went
off so they all applauded of course
Nelson Mandela unjustly went to jail for
27 years Steven colar you hack which is
exactly what could potentially happen to
Donald Trump whether or not he's done
some things that he shouldn't have the
selective prosecution here of course is
absolutely ridiculous but it's not just
crime and this is the this is what I
want to link to everything else it's
culture it's erasing of everything that
is our history and what we know to be
good and bad and then ushering in this
aoral driil where we don't know where we
came from so now allow me to link it to
something else you may have seen this
the black history museum has melted down
a statue of General Robert E Lee now we
know that General Robert E Lee was on
the wrong side of the Civil War I am not
defending Robert E Lee or slavery if we
melt down burn down tear down every
statue of our history how will we ever
know who the good guys and bad guys were
and do you think they will stop with
just the people who are the bad guys
probably not here's some video of the
black Museum taken out Robert
E
[Music]
people were very excited about that
again it's not a defense of Robert E Lee
to to not want the statue there uh I
have said this many times the better way
to deal with complex people of history
and figures who are controversial and
using all of our morals and ideals of
today is that if there's a statue of
somebody you don't rip it down perhaps
some of them you could move to a museum
so you don't lose the historical context
but what you could do in some of these
cases is put a plaque that explains a
bit more so okay this statue was put up
in in deference in honor of this person
but as time has gone by and we have
learned more here is what we think of
the history now so if you don't want him
in public you put him in a museum not in
our in a furnace because when we lose
our history we will lose our future
right we will literally if we lose the
history not that we'll lose the future
we won't know how to get to a decent
future that really is the problem and
that now is what is happening all over
our college campuses and in a very
Twisted way all over many of our biggest
cities so here is a pramas rally in
Brooklyn New York Brooklyn New York
which of course is home to one of the
largest populations of Jews in the
United States and they're calling for
River to the Sea which is a genoz chant
and bunch more and the New York City
Police Department which is which is
certainly not the NYPD of old of the old
days right this is not Rudy giuliani's
NYPD these are these are largely good
people who are trying many of them have
retired early uh many of them have now
been brought down to Florida because the
santis has said to these guys hey if you
don't want to work there and you're good
and you're decent we'll we'll take you
down here so one of the other things
happening right now is that the blue
states are losing their good police
officers because the administrations
don't back them this is a problem uh it
got a little V in in Brooklyn with the
pro Hamas and by the way I have no
problem calling these people pramas
protesters people keep saying well
they're not all for Hamas I have yet to
see
anyone literally one person at any of
these rallies that is out there with the
sign I'm for the Gins but I am against
Hamas right these all of these things
all of these protests broke out after
Hamas killed about 1,400 Israelis and
still have 200 uh hostages including
about a dozen Americans which nobody
seems to care about anyway here's
Brooklyn uh just in the last day or
[Music]
[Applause]
two I got to say the police are trying
they are trying to let people peace
protest one of the things that we are
going to be challenged on going forward
constantly is what are the limits of
free speech if you are chanting for
genocide how close does that get to a
direct threat of violence if you are
targeting as they've done in London
repeatedly now uh if you target just a
random store owned by a Jew for your
anti-israel supposed protests are you
infringing on the rights of that person
to own their store right to basically
run a business and we know this thing is
far more than anger over Israel's
response to what happened in southern
Israel right this was all coordinated
was all ready just think back to BLM
they turn this thing on when they want
and they turn it off when they don't
want and by the way that is deeply
connected to George Soros and the people
who fund all of these organizations
right BLM was funded to the tunes of
hundreds hundreds of millions of dollars
if not billions of dollars did they send
one black kid to College we could do a
little research on that did they open
one black shop did they do anything
about urban renewal in Black communities
or did they just get a bunch of people a
bunch of grifters real Rich well when
you watch those people and by the way
you know it's a it's a strange
Confluence I'd say you have some genuine
kind of like islamists out there who
want to take down the United States and
we have to figure out if they're here
legally or not and that distinction is
important when figuring out what to do
with them that's one thing then you have
like the set of like confused you
know college kids and whatever then you
have just like some like just kind of
like a bunch of losers with nothing to
do and you know it's like okay that
that's kind of what's all going on there
but the point is they make up some
intersectional disgusting Coalition of
lunatics and unfortunately we as a
society right now we don't know what to
do about that we don't and I have to
tell you having been in London like the
people of London they don't know what to
do of it there're it's not that most
people in London are are these radical
uh radical people cheering on the death
of Jews of course not I would venture to
say it's far more it's probably 90% of
the people that are against it I don't
have the exact numbers we're going to
work on getting some numbers on that and
I think especially in America we
certainly most people are not for this
but the good people the the huge silent
majority we simply do not know what to
do about them because we've in some
Essence lost the culture War so we don't
have enough good people out there
fighting this stuff uh one good person
who's out there fighting this stuff is H
Ric you know her better she's better
known as Libs of Tik tock on Twitter and
she just does an absolute uh great job
she has confronted some of the people
from our Hamas caucus uh on the floors
of the house many times here she is in
the last day or two uh going after AOC
and trying to get her to condemn Hamas
or anything and and just like we've
shown you these videos from ilhan Omar
we've shown you these videos from
Rashida TB they seem incapable of
condemning people who literally put
children into Ovens that seems a bridge
too far for these people take a look hey
can I grab a photo with you hi
thanks oh hi so when you told me you
never wanted to share space with me I
never want to share space with you thank
you is it cuz you're part of the Hamas
caucus and I'm Jewish all right no it's
cuz you're a transp thank you oh okay so
to go so oh are you heading to Hamas
Caucus meeting
when's the next one you know there are
Americans being held
hostage do you
care do you care that Hamas is holding
Americans
hostage what do you say to the families
of Americans who are currently being
held hostage by
Hamas does the Hamas caucus have a
statement about
it I is really great you know that's not
easy to do to get in somebody's face
like it looks could be fun or silly but
like it's not the easiest thing to do
I've been around these people and
security and you don't know what they're
going to do to you so that's just a
beautiful moment but notice AOC again
she just simply cannot condemn these
people and and she was so excited to
take the picture at first and then she
realized oh oh uh oh uhoh it's her and
then what is what is her answer why
doesn't she like her because she's
transphobic which means that haa has an
irrational fear of trans people no that
is not true and the word much like
islamophobic is completely ridiculous
it's not about an IR rational fear it in
this case is more about she doesn't want
little boys wangs cut off so that they
can pretend that they're girls in the
name of Tolerance and
diversity all right so AOC and and by
the way as you know AOC has no knowledge
of of the history or anything else and
the revolution will eat her the way the
revolution is eating Bernie Sanders
who's largely IR irrelevant Hallelujah
the the revolution will eventually eat
AOC so there is a silver lining to all
of this guys but the point is that
people like AOC and the political class
who I is ushering this in intentionally
or just sort of burying their heads in
the sand they have been funded by guys
like George Soros and that millu of
people are basically looking excuse me
to take out all of Western Heritage and
it's not just here in the United States
I want to show you a video of the
Scottish labor party leader his name is
anas sarir and he is very upset that
there's so many people that are white in
Scotland every chief executive of every
Council and every government Department
white every director of a department in
Scotland white every principal of a
college of University in Scotland white
every head teacher in Scotland white
every chair of a public sector body in
Scotland white every high court judge in
Scotland white every present governor in
Scotland white every editor of a news
organization in Scotland white why you
know every time I've watched Braveheart
I've always thought that Mel Gibson
should have been cast as a black guy it
would always I found it personally
offensive um that guy is is there only
to destroy Scotland let's be very very
clear about it actually in the interview
if you want to know a little bit more
about him and by the oh you're not going
to believe this his wife is Palestinian
um if you want to know a bit more about
him in my interview that we're going to
put up next week as I said I did about
20 interviews throughout the week uh
with Douglas Murray he really Douglas is
in Douglas is in sh such sharp based
Douglas Murray mode he has been warning
about all of this for years right his
book The Strange death of Europe from
what seven years ago uh he is he is just
so sharp and and focused and clear on
all of this I have two Scotti employees
in the studio right now do you have
Scottish blood do you you I feel like
you must have Scottish blood who's my
other you have Scottish BL my and look
at you Conor is literally the whitest
person I've ever seen he's going after
you he's going after you you at least
have a little more colors from Italy or
something anyway the point the point is
Scotland okay they have white people
these people are here to destroy the
west and if you don't see that already
you can bury your head in the sand but
that just means that they will behead
you a lower a little bit lower on the
neck that's how it works now I want to
show you something um because uh you
know the few days before I went to
London I actually was debating whether I
was going to go at all because of these
crazy uh these crazy protests there
these Hamas rallies they again they are
Hamas rallies I will say that until
proven wrong until you get me a rally of
a couple th000 people chanting no Hamas
uh then I'm going to call them Hamas
rallies uh this was was the massive one
this was just hours before I landed in
London take a
[Applause]
look
they say that was over 100,000 people I
don't know about the exact numbers uh
that you saw Big Ben in that picture
beautiful building we we were right
there we were right there we walked by
that actually one night I was going to
dinner we were in a car and we drove
right by one of the Hamas rallies um the
question is really um do you think these
people are proud British
citizens who is more indigenous to the
land do you think it's the ancient it's
the Jews in the ancient land of Israel
the Bible all of that stuff the story
where Jesus was from and where Hanukkah
took place and all that do you think the
Jews have a little more connection with
that land or those 100,000 people who
are somehow in Britain there to
undermine the very Western values that
allowed them to be there in the first
place that is the question and as I have
said repeatedly and will continue to say
if you if you don't care about Jews and
you don't care about Israel it's fine it
actually is fine right like everyone can
care about the what whatever is
important in your hierarchy of things
you care about that's just fine but if
you think that if they take out that
tiny little country the size of New
Jersey and wipe out all the Jews there
if you think that those people in London
and in Paris and in Brussels and in
Amsterdam are going to wash their hands
and be like okay we're good let's go
home and let's be great citizens and
build a great free country no they will
have been empowered and emboldened and
they will come for everybody else of
course the next part of this I believe
this is also from London check out this
flag this this is very exciting from one
of these uh protests they have combined
The Psychotic and racist trans flag so
you have people who want to chop the
genitals off children they have combined
that with the p the Palestinian Hamas
flag which is better noted for wanting
to chop the heads off babies so whether
it is your genitals or your head you
will be severely wounded by The End by
the time they are done with you uh okay
so now that we shown you what's going on
in London today and by the way all
things being equal I had a nice time in
London as I said the the the event
itself I was largely just going from the
hotel to the event I did go to a couple
dinners and things I had a nice time in
London there were a lot of good people
in London the the British people are
waking up to this so I am notching all
the people of of Great Britain I am not
going after all the londoners again good
people don't know exactly what to do but
when you see those 100,000 people
marching out there and and you know you
you just know it in your bones they
don't care about Britain they are there
to invade they are calling for their
islamist armies they are calling for the
rise of from The River To The Sea and
all of those things what do you think
the future of London will look like well
I would recommend you read any of
Douglas Murray's books or watch the
interview we're going to have in a
couple days we thought we' we've shown
you this once before but I thought it
was worth noting again because it was in
my head the entire time I was London uh
here's London in
[Music]
a beautiful architecture people going
about their business well-dressed the
society on its way up with a great
history right right like Britain London
England there's a great history there of
Western values and then since 1960 what
has happened massive
migration massive open borders that have
allowed all sorts of people to come in
and have their own little pockets we
actually drove through one of the little
pockets that let's just say if Dave
Rubin had got out of the car it probably
wouldn't have gone that well um they had
now have infected their society with
something that the good people of their
society don't know what to do with they
had a beautiful flower an absolutely
beautiful flower but today that flower
has been cut from its roots and what
happens when a flower is cut from its
roots well here's ion hery ali uh on
stage with Jordan Peterson and a couple
other people at the alliance for
responsible citizenship conference that
I was at but what I the quotes that you
just had about you know Western
Civilization is a Cut Flower and cut
flowers die
that is true cut flowers die that is
true so what do we do because we are
seeing now that whether it's in America
to a lesser extent I would say largely
in Western Europe some of the places I
mentioned France Britain Belgium Holland
they have a much bigger problem with all
of this but the purpose of the Ark
conference to was to try to figure out
what is the story what is the story that
we knew that we forgot that we must
remember so we can get out of this mess
ion continued cut flowers do die but
what we have in terms of Western
Civilization is a lot of seed
packets and I want to send you off with
these seed packets which you find in
libraries which you find in you know
Wise people like you like Roger scrutin
like all these other people that I
mentioned uh in statues we have the
remnants the symbols of Western Heritage
and their seeds and all we have to do
those of us who inherited it and enjoy
it is to go and Seed them grow them
nurture them water them and when they're
attacked fight for
them God I I I just adore that woman I
did have a sit down with ion hery Ali
that you'll see as well I've had ion a
few times on the show her story is she
is the living breathing embodiment of
how good the West is a woman who was
born in Sudan Dan who underwent female
genital mutilation who was forced to be
married who was raped who eventually
made it to Holland uh became a member of
parliament in Holland along with Theo
van go Vincent Van Go's was it his son
or grandson I'm blanking who was
assassinated on the streets of Amsterdam
by an islamist and then they pinned a
note on Theo van go basically saying ion
we're coming for you next thus she moved
to the United States of America uh but
what she's talking about there we have
the seeds
and you know what those seeds are those
seeds are are things like individual
rights those seeds are things like free
speech knowing where we came from and
how we got there now I want to show you
this video that I'm guessing you've
probably seen it because it went super
super viral but this is just so great
this made me proud you know so much of
what I see out of New York City these
days I'm like oh man like that's just so
not the New York City that I once knew
um and and and lived in for 20 years my
most formative years in my you know like
early 20s into into mid3 s um here is a
video from New York City I think it's in
Queens actually uh and watch as one of
these people one of these awful human
beings I don't know if he's there
legally or not uh he's ripping down
signs of kidnapped and murdered children
in Israel we don't know why he's doing
that I mean you could be for the
whatever you believe to be the plight of
the Palestinians still understand that
kidnapping and murdering children is not
a good idea but watch the way some of
these true New Yorkers this guy is such
a true New Yorker watch how they respond
this is so absolutely beautiful now what
are you doing you know where they are
right now you have any idea where they
are right
now all right I'm a veteran I'm telling
you I'm Jewish he's not Jewish I don't
know if he is not doesn't matter this is
in the US New York City you don't have a
right to touch that this is a free
country you can away your Palestine flag
and say death to the Jews or America
whenever you want but we can put a signs
okay I'm not then don't rip that down
you are doing something you're offending
us mother the yeah you are when you
throw that on the floor you're lering
the city in a minute I'm going to LIT
her on the floor with you you have a
proof so move the on do you have proof
they not kidnapped no so shut the
up I know that's what you
want in the
hospital I mean it's so good the emotion
and the spirit that New York used to
have right like and and yes he got as
close as you can get without punching
somebody and all of that stuff I have
been trying to find this guy online
apparently we were able to find one of
the other guys but I got a thousand
bucks I will treat that guy to Peter
Luger Steakhouse or whatever he wants to
do in New York with all his friends or
whatever if I can get up there I'd be
happy to go up and and and break bread
with him and those guys and how
beautiful like it doesn't matter as he
said I'm not Jewish he's not Jewish it
doesn't matter we believe in America
right and it's like and that the other
guy I'm a veteran like and this
disgusting Pig and that's what that man
is he has nothing he has nothing to say
absolutely nothing to say so that guy
right there with the with the glasses on
his head showing the passion and showing
the belief and showing the spirit of
America he's the one that's actually
replanting the seeds because if we don't
start getting some of that attitude all
of us if all of us dare I say it don't
get a backbone like a ramrod uh we are
going to continue The Descent to hell so
now I want to show you and I think we're
going to try to uh play this full video
we're going to see if we get it from the
ark Folks at the end of the Ark
conference which again was three days of
academics and political leaders and
thinkers and influencers and all these
people giving incredible speeches I kid
you not when I say this I am not being
hyperbolic or sarcastic or or
exaggerating Jordan Peterson gave the
best speech I have ever heard in my life
not just the best Jordan Peterson speech
the best speech I have ever heard in my
life it was a distillation of everything
I have ever seen this man do and let's
not I forget I toured with the guy for a
year and a half 120 shows about 20
countries I saw him take all of the work
he has ever done and combine it I want
to show you it's about a minute and a
half clip uh just a portion of it we'll
we'll try to repost the full thing but
perhaps guys there are some answers and
sort of where we started at the
beginning of the show perhaps we just
have to look backwards to figure out
that we are actually a piece of the
thing that might fix it perhaps Jordan
and that's what's happening to the young
people that we see who are a drift
they're taught to be nothing but
self-conscious to do nothing but think
about their immediate needs to refer to
themselves as the Locust of all things
and there's nothing you could do that
would make them more miserable it's
identical with the instruction in misery
and you want to be outside yourself
serving a higher purpose and maybe
you're cynical about that but you can
think about it technically why do you
bring a fork to the table well so that
you can put a plate beside it and why do
you put a plate at the table and so that
you can set the table to serve your
family to share food to bring together
the people you love in something
approximating Harmony as a microcosm of
the entire Cosmic order and you can
replicate that at every level of
complexity all the way up to what's at
the Pinnacle and that's all real and so
is what's at the Pinnacle and we've
forgotten all of that and as a
consequence of forgetting that we've
forgotten the responsibility that we
need to bear in our life to make our
lives bearable and we've forgotten the
meaning and the adventure and the
purpose and the significance and this
and the earned self-regard that goes
along with that sacrificial attitude and
we've forgotten to tell our children the
same thing and we could remember we
could remember who we are we could
remember who we are and that's what the
this conference was for to remind people
everyone who attends who you are right
you're the the
the I telling you guys I sat in that
room with over a thousand people you
could not only hear a pin drop which
I've been through that with Jordan many
times before but I don't know that there
was a dry eye in there I when you hear
truth what I always tell you we play all
these clips of these politicians lying
and you can feel it in your body it's
not right it's not good it's why they're
always screaming in in then something
like truth comes and you hear it and it
gets in you right and that is what
Jordan is asking us to remember I'm also
reminded it's funny I didn't even think
of this when I was hearing it the first
time one of the things that I really
like to do and I actually wrote about it
in in don't burn this country like we
love having big dinner parties here I
love setting the table and it finally
connected in my mind literally I was
just watching that I was there live for
it I've watched it twice since but it
just hit me like there was a it's not
just to have a nice table it's like
there is a reason that if you set the
table properly and and then you invite
people over and they dress a certain way
and you all sort of believe in in
whatever your shared values are let's
say the values of goodness and community
and decency and you share a meal and you
talk about things that you start seeding
the ground as Ian asked us to do you
start seating the ground for a better
Society so we're almost at the end of
the show today so I now want to go back
to just an image remember that family
that we showed you it doesn't matter as
I said earlier within the context of how
describing it it does not matter whether
they're here illegally or not it matters
in a meta sense but for the purposes of
stealing the candy it doesn't remember
it so let's show you a picture of that
family again we don't have to show you
the full thing so here they are and
there was also a young guy there that
you can't quite see in the yellow and
they're just grabbing all the candy
taking from everybody they are stealing
they are showing their kids it's okay to
steal they're going to get fat and their
teeth are going to rot and they're going
to get everything they deserve and
that's what they're doing to
society but there's a better
way
a that was really
nice there go like I want that
one how about we all fill up that
what do you think I'll do it if you will
uh guys Parts one and two of my
interview with RFK on location in Los
Angeles are up right now the full things
on locals of course uh if you have not
joined us on Rumble rumble.com rubben
report postgame show as I said coming up
right now at Ruben report. locals.com
and later today we're running our first
test of the new call-in show which will
debut next week that's you guys being
part of the show uncensored I want to
hear what you think about things I have
often said in in the midst of anything
if I've learned learned anything over
the last couple years and I like to
think I've learned a couple things uh
it's that often you guys have as much if
not more insight than a lot of the
people that I'm sitting down with so
I've wanted to do this show for a long
time I'm psyched that we're going to
finally launch it so we're doing our
first test version and if you want to uh
be part of that and then be part of the
queue of people that will be selecting
to be on the show you can join us at
Ruben
report. I was about to say the show is a
10 the rare 10 and then I got Ruben
report. locals.com wrong all right we're
going to 99 this thing we leave you with
another guy who knew a little something
about what your responsibility in
society is and we'll see everybody on
the other side and so my fellow
Americans ask not what your country can
do for you ask what you can do for your
[Music]
country